americans are worried about a lot of
things besides baby formula according to
the latest cbs news poll nearly
three-quarters of people have been
surveyed and they said that things are
going badly in america right now and
more than two-thirds of the us say the
economy is bad that's an increase of
more than 20 percent from last year all
these concerns are part of the backdrop
for tomorrow's primary elections around
the country ed o'keefe is in atlanta
covering georgia's republican primary
another test of former president trump's
influence ed good morning
nate great to see you inflation
certainly a top concern for voters we've
spoken to here there are four southern
states holding contests on tuesday but
we're here in georgia because as you
said the former president is personally
involved in several of the primaries
being held let's start with the u.s
senate where trump's hand-picked
candidate herschel walker the former
football star is forgive the analogy
nate running away with the ball and
likely to win easily on tuesday setting
himself up for a general election
matchup against democratic senator
rafael warnock in what could be the most
expensive and decisive senate race this
year but the primary here in georgia the
former president is perhaps most
concerned about is the one involving
governor brian kemp he's being
challenged by former senator david
perdue who's jumped into the race at
trump's earth trump's urging kemp is
leading in the polls by large margins
and remains a popular figure here and
notably later today former vice
president mike pence is going to
campaign alongside kemp in open defiance
of the former president a sign there are
still republicans across the country who
believe somebody other than the former
president could emerge as the gop's 2024
presidential nominee and remember if
brian kemp wins that primary as expected
he's setting himself up for a rematch
with the democrat stacey abrams gail all
right
we've seen that song before too ed thank
you very much